These days, Super Bowl halftime shows are
star-studded affairs that can eclipse the
game itself.
More people watched Madonna’s 2012 halftime
performance than the Patriots and Giants matchup
(despite it being thrilling).
In 2007, everyone remembers Prince crooning
“Purple Rain” during an actual torrential
rainstorm.
Also, the Indianapolis Colts beat the Chicago
Bears in a rather uneventful game.
In 1993, the King of Pop Michael Jackson staged
a legendary halftime performance that cemented
his and football’s status as American cultural
icons.
Few recall that the Dallas Cowboys destroyed
the Buffalo Bills that year by a score of
53 to 17.
(Incidentally, this fourth consecutive loss
in the Super Bowl by the Bills, nonetheless,
was a win for the world in helping to popularize
the Buffalo Wing– now a staple food item
of any good Super Bowl party.)
Until Michael Jackson in 1993, pop stars really
didn’t perform at the Super Bowl.
But it didn’t mean the halftime show was
boring.
Here’s the story of the first Super Bowl
halftime show, which featured jetpacks, 300
pigeons and a weird old west shootout.
In 1959, the American Football League (AFL)
formed to compete with the emerging National
Football League (NFL).
With many teams from the west and south (like
the Los Angeles Chargers, Houston Oilers and
Kansas City Chiefs), the AFL emphasized a
more pass-heavy game than the NFL.
The league also came up with fan-friendly
innovations that are still seen in sports
today, like putting names on the back of uniforms
and two-point conversations.
By 1966, it became clear that the AFL could
potentially pass the NFL as the country’s
premier football league.
So, the two leagues merged in June 1966 with
all eight AFL teams joining the NFL.
It was also agreed that, although the two
leagues would not play each other in the regular
season, the two best teams would meet in a
championship game at the end of the year.
Sort of half-jokingly, Chiefs’ owner Lamar
Hunt proposed they call it the “Super Bowl,”
at least until a better name was thought up.
Rather oddly, Super Bowl I actually wasn’t
officially known as that until two years after
the fact.
On January 15, 1967, the AFL’s Kansas City
Chiefs and NFL’s the Green Bay Packers played
in a game that was originally billed as the
AFL-NFL World Championship in Los Angeles.
However, promotional materials and press mentioned
it as a “Super Bowl,” taking Hunt’s
suggestion.
But the NFL commissioner Pete Rozelle still
clung to the very uncatchy name of the “AFL-NFL
World Championship.”
Finally, in 1969, the commissioner relented
and officially renamed the championship game
the “Super Bowl,” while retroactively
naming the two games that were played under
the old moniker “Super Bowl I” and “Super
Bowl II.”
This brings us to the first Super Bowl halftime
show.
Tommy Walker may not be as famous as other
Super Bowl heroes like Joe Namath, Whitney
Houston or Lynn Swann, but he perhaps had
more of an impact on what the big game has
since become than them.
Once known as “Tommy the Toe” for his
kicking acumen while at USC, Walker also was
an accomplished drummer and sometimes actor
who earned a Bronze Star as a scout for the
Army during World War II.
He was a natural showman who, as USC’s band
director, would put on halftime shows that
involved card stunts and pigeon releases.
His eccentric performances caught the attention
of another showman, Walt Disney, who hired
him to organize and direct the 1955 opening
ceremonies for his new theme park – Disneyland
– in Anaheim.
He’s credited with ­designing what has
since become iconic Disney theme park pageantry,
including Tinker Bell’s wire descent from
the Matterhorn and the fireworks above Cinderella’s
castle.
According to Sports Illustrated, it was Walker
who convinced commissioner Rozelle that the
first championship game between the AFL and
NFL needed his own special brand of flair.
The commissioner was reportedly at first reluctant
to spend the money because, as SI quoted him,
“Why would we spend all that money?
That’s when everybody goes to the bathroom.”
However, he was soon convinced and Walker
went to work.
rocketIn his planning for the first Super
Bowl Halftime Show, Walker literally reached
for the sky.
Two years earlier, he had hired Bill Suitor
– perhaps the world’s foremost jet pack
pilot who had given himself the nickname “Mr.
Jetpack” – to soar over Disneyland.
Now, Walker asked him to join him in entertaining
the football-watching crowd.
Next, Walker reached out to more traditional
entertainment – two college marching bands,
one from the University of Arizona and another
from Grambling University.
This was significant because Grambling was
a small Louisiana school and a historically
black college.
At a time when racial tension was hanging
over America (especially in LA, where the
Watts riots had raged only a few months before),
this choice held symbolic meaning.
Walker also got famous trumpeter Al Hirt to
perform for free with one condition: That
part of the show was a tribute to his beloved
New Orleans, who had just been awarded an
NFL team a few months earlier.
As the two teams headed to the locker rooms
for halftime with the Packers leading the
Chiefs 14 to 10, the 200 person University
of Arizona marching band took the field at
the Los Angeles Memorial Coliseum for the
halftime show that was titled “Super Sights
and Sounds.”
Marching up the field, they were joined by
“world champion baton twirler Richard Smith”
who performed a quick routine.
Next, the band shifted into the next stage
of the program, which was to pay tribute to
the four corners of the United States.
Forming into a southern riverboat, they were
accompanied by Hirt, who played an assortment
of New Orleans-inspired solos while the band
formed again into a trumpet and musical notes.
Next, to symbolize the west, they created
Arizona’s iconic OK corral while old west
gunman took aim at one another in recreating
the famous shootout between Wyatt Earp and
Doc Holliday and the McLaury brothers.
(Though the popular perception of Earp and
Holliday isn’t exactly accurate today- see:
Wyatt Earp, the Great American Villain and
The Real Doc Holliday.)
There were blasts, gun smoke and, rather morbidly,
mortally wounded scattered across the field.
Moving on, the band acted out the “industry
in the north” with several actors stuffing
what looked to be big yellow coins into a
makeshift machine.
Finally, they moved to the Mid-Atlantic region
and formed a giant liberty bell, which of
course, soon cracked.
The pageantry didn’t stop there, however,
with the marching band eventually forming
into two stick figure football players who
were to kick two giant footballs, symbolizing
the coming together of the two leagues.
However, right before the footballs were to
be so-called “kicked,” out sprang the
jetpack-wearing Suitor and a partner.
Flying high above the field, they landed in
the middle to great applause.
After this, the Arizona band was joined by
Grambling University’s marching band to
create a giant map of the US, where each team
of the newly formed NFL was introduced to
the fans.
Finally, the two bands were accompanied by
the USC song chorus for a rendition of “This
is My Country,” punctuated by the release
of thousands of multi-colored balloons and
300 pigeons.
The nearly 15-minute performance was a cross
between a Disneyland parade, an Olympics opening
ceremonies and a college football halftime
performance.
It was unlike anything anyone had ever seen
and set the stage for all Super Bowl Halftimes
Shows for years to come.
And they didn’t need Michael Jackson or
U2 to make it memorable.